Rachel,
I wanted to kill you while you were still beautiful
But
don't worry, the
ground is dark and cool and you're black
Rachel,
I'll take you there
ha
me
No matter how high your cardiopulmonary capacity is, you're empty-headed, so you're not really able to kill me, so
you're frustrated all the time.  Usuhimi, who sells frustrated girls and sells, is
shinier
I want only you, Rachel
.
If you can't see
me, follow me I'm always digging for a
fleeting moment in the dark, so I can see even in the dark
That's right, you turn on the light here and see me There
must be a switch somewhere, but it's pitch black
So don't tell me to turn it on
That's amazing [music] Wild intuition